ces trois hommes ont merdé il ya une
personne qui doit dire quelque chose sur
la propriété ne va pas commencer
maintenant c'est simple je vous répéter
ce que je vous ai déjà dit il faut gérer
tout ça ok y'a pas de soucis donné le
manque à gagner
j'ai eu le procureur comme chez moi j'ai
eu le fisc est venu chez moi qui m'a
contrôle et j'ai tout eu on m'a rien
fait on m'a dit non monsieur vous ne
dépassez pas les bornes vous dépassez
rien et vous venez encore mon père d
aller me coucher je suis vous êtes mais
vous croyez quoi être maire christian
bresson l'a toujours vécu comme un
sacerdoce
mais là il n'en peut plus il a été
agressé verbalement et même physiquement
parce qu'il veut mettre fin à ce
dépotoir et répondre ainsi aux attentes
des voisins on se font tout seuls et on
le monde un peu des deux laitages enfin
par le biais de la préfecture par tout
ça pour nous aider mais je pense que
pour l'instant c'est d'être bon
christian bresson ne se représentera pas
aux élections de 2020 avec son équipe
ils se sont passionnés pour la
rénovation de leur patrimoine
mais la coupe est pleine trop
d'incivilités panneaux démontés camions
de pompiers vandalisés c'est le premier
été sans gendarmerie dans le village on
avait une bonne coopération avec la
gendarmerie et tout ça par rapport à
préparer les étés étaient ceints par
rapport à la jeunesse
je pense que c'est d'ailleurs c'est pour
ça que ça monte en puissance
une violence qui peut aller jusqu'à la
mort d'anne élu en août le maire de sin
s'était opposé un dépôt dans une
décharge sauvage
ses obsèques ont révélé le mal être
profond des mers un électrochoc saisi
par le sénat pour analyser les menaces
et agressions sur les élus via un
questionnaire envoyé aux maires les
sénateurs l'utiliseront pour faire des
propositions au gouvernement c'est le
malaise on va dire d'une société qui
change est d'une société qui respecte -
les représentants des institutions
certes mais c'est également le malaise
des maires il se trouve en grande
difficulté d'exercer leurs fonctions
dans sa mairie de sault christian
bresson a répondu à lenquête à la
question 17 lui demandant s'il dispose
des moyens de contrainte suffisante pour
faire respecter ces arrêtés il a répondu
non pour lui cette initiative du sénat
vient trop tard
c'est vrai que d'être tout le temps on
écoute du des habitants et tout ça ça
use mais vu l'évolution
je ne pense pas que ça va s'effacer
comme ça d'un coup de baguette magique
les sénateurs devraient s'appuyer sur
les résultats de cette enquête pour
examiner le projet de loi du
gouvernement qui tentera de rétablir la
confiance avec le monde rural un débat
prévu à l'automne seulement en six mois
avant les élections municipales